a big thank you to allergy season for
making me actually look like I'm on
crystal meth Breaking Bad so Breaking
Bad's a series that's on AMC about a guy
who breaks bad by that I'm talking about
Walter White who's a genius level
chemist I mean the guy could have cured
cancer if he put his mind to it but
instead he's a teacher and it definitely
overqualified one and he's diagnosed
with terminal lung cancer he doesn't
have money to pay for the treatment he
doesn't have insurance and he's probably
gonna die and leave his family with a
shitload of day and so to pay for the
treatment and financially said his
family up after he dies he realizes he
can make a lot of money really fast by
cooking crystal meth he realizes this
because his brother-in-law's an agent
for the DEA and one of his bus was on
the news and they sees like 700,000
dollars and he's just like I could do
that and I could do it better because
I'm a genius level chemist and so he
finds out that one of his former
students Jesse deals crystal meth and so
he's pretty much like alright man so in
the words of the pet shop boys I got the
brains you got the looks let's make lots
of money and so they do the one thing
people tell me about the series the
reason they don't want to watch it
because they feel like it like
advertises and advocates crystal meth it
absolutely doesn't it's not like some
public service announcement like so
life's got you down you need a solution
got one crystal meth because it just
makes life better no it actually does a
really good job at showing the decline
of Walter White from this really nerdy
quiet smart guy to one of the most
sought-after crystal meth cooks known as
Heisenberg Heisenberg the alias he goes
under this guy cooks some pyramids I'm
not a meth head so I don't know what's
really pure and what's not but it's like
ninety-nine point seven percent pure and
since crystal meth is pretty much made
out of battery acid and dog you
know he has a pretty good job and also
the series shows that when you do
something like this when you deal in a
world like this a there's really no get
now and be you're gonna make some
friends and you're gonna piss off the
rest which he really does and this show
is really well acted to Bryan Cranston
plays Walter White
the guy's won an Emmy I think every year
the show's been on and yeah he deserves
it he is awesome cooking meth has turned
the guy from this into this yeah and I
like the characters too like Walter
White and Jesse Walter White's clearly
the leader taking Jesse under his wing
and they just bicker and fight all the
time cuz Jesse thinks he's smarter than
Walter Wyatt and he's just not and Jesse
does like really dumb a lot of
times and Walter White's wife I'll say
that I hate the lady I don't know why I
just
like her and it's funny cuz she's just
not wrong she suspects that Walter
White's hiding something from her which
he is something really big probably
doesn't suspect his as big as it is
because he cooks meth and she gets pissy
with him and I just hate her I'm just
like you I shouldn't be though
because she's in the right what can I
say she's mean to the Heisenberg no one
disrespects the Heisenberg and in
entering the criminal world he has to do
like criminal things like launder money
so he has to get this really sleazy ass
lawyer that looks like Kevin Costner's
love child and it's just it's a downward
spiral from normal suburban life into
like villainy it does a good job showing
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions he doesn't want to be an
he just wants to set up his
family but you know he deals in a
product that you know ruins lives and
now this show is a drama and it's
thick it's not funny although it has its
funny moments usually with Jesse or
situational humor but all in all you're
getting into a drama every season is
darker than the last season there are
some things that Walter White does
really like dude you are not even Walter
White anymore the Walter White in
episode one would never have done that
sometimes people got to die if you want
to live seasons 1 through 3 are out on
blu-ray season 4 airs on AMC starting
July 17 so I say check it out and on a
side note there's a YouTube contest
called YouTube Nextup know I personally
did not enter it but my friends OMFG
it's Jack and Dean dick and they're
really funny they're just really
hilarious I wouldn't be saying this if I
didn't think there were I never stood
you guys wrong with crystal meth shows
and comedy on YouTube so be sure to vote
for them for YouTube Nextup I put a link
below to their video showing you how you
can this is me giving a little back to
the world they feel like Karma's gonna
dick slap me if I don't and as always if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more why because it just makes life
better
you